so I understand you work with casting
director is it Emily Webber yes okay can
you give us some tips on how you cast a
movie from far away your back you know
close to the East Coast right now and
then you come back and forth to LA how
is that done what's what's the best way
of choosing actors from far away when
you're not in LA
well I oh I mean Emily and I have been
working together ever since Steel City
and I was very unfamiliar with the
casting process so I owe my knowledge of
how this all works to her and she just
sort of taught me what to look for and
the audition process and working with
actors in the room that that's you know
that's something I didn't know I didn't
understand that and that's a skill and
and you really learn a lot about
directing when you're given a small
opportunity an actor gives you a read
and then you have to give them a very
brief direction or a very brief motive
as to how they can how they can very
simply and wisely alter their
performance for what you're looking for
what the character that the the dynamics
the character in this very brief time
and that's hard to do and as a director
you can you can you can recognize okay
this person has got something I like but
you're not seeing it in the room and
Emily you know taught me through all her
years of experience how to do that how
to maneuver that how to navigate that in
the room and then that translates to set
which is you know on set you have that's
a whole different beast but getting back
to actors I you know as a just as a
movie lover in general you're constantly
watching movies and seeing good
performances and people you want to work
with and the casting director just gives
you recommendations and you should
people you never would have thought of
ever and they have this sense of of
finding talent that might be uniquely
great for your project and they they see
something in them like well in 10 years
I think this person is really going to
have you know blossom into a leading man
or a leading lady and they kind of have
that it's this weird thing that's
interesting do they share with you what
that is sometimes when you see that is
that because sometimes I'll see people
that are really sort of vulnerable on
screen and a lot of times I find that
people really relate to that whereas
those that come in like I'm acting and
they're part of them they never really
turn right but I I think it's very I
think you know acting is very intuitive
I honestly believe you can't learn it I
don't I know they have all these acting
schools I think you can develop
technique but I think you're either born
being able you just have the gift of you
know turning that switch on and being
somebody else or you can and I think it
also has to do with you find the best
actors I know are very cerebral
intelligent people and when they talk to
you you get a sense of wow this person
really understands they have a empathy
and a sympathy for the human condition
and and what it's like to they realize
that that there's that they just
navigate through life and they very
wisely pick and choose what they're
gonna let in and what they're gonna let
out and I've never met a great I don't
know how to say this
all the people I've worked with have
been very very smart intelligent wise
people and I don't think there's a
coincidence that they're also great
actors at that that makes any sense yeah
I think it does deep do you think that
you're casting people for who they are
as people a lot of times when they come
in that door when you do actually get to
be in LA or even if you're in Alton or
wherever casting them or do you see
people that they do have another side to
them that doesn't come out
to the public persona um well I think a
lot of it has to do with who they are as
human beings you know how they look
their mannerisms you know I was just in
the casting session the other day and my
casting director said that person's to
cosmetic that pert you know there's a
little bit something to cosmetic for
your story you know it's almost like you
know I'm dealing with Midwest themes and
blue-collar and this and you know she
would say you're not gonna believe that
that actress you're not gonna believe
her that she's gonna step out of a car
in the Midwest and you know that's just
not gonna be believable so I tend to go
towards a more real looking you know
people that have lived life I mean cuz
you can't be a great actor if you move
out here when you're 18 years old and do
nothing but audition and work in a
coffee shop like lift some life man I
mean that applies for anything you do
unless your doctor and you really have
to like learn how to be a surgeon but
you know like live life get out there
you know otherwise you're never gonna
know what it's like to place someone
real and also to those those depths
you know you mean you know that's about
the same thing when projects are falling
apart things come too easy I think to
maybe people don't write just say be
cool man it's all good you know but but
sometimes life isn't all good and I
think that's sometimes where people get
some great realness to them and you have
you well then you have this new crop of
actors that become actors just through
sheer just through nepotism and they've
grown up in Hollywood they've grown up
in a bubble and they're all the sudden
actors which is fine I mean that's the
way a lot of businesses work and but I
don't think you're gonna get any I you
know
you